looking back on it
that was camelot
that was camelot
that was the greatest experience for
everyone involved that they'll ever have
in their life to go through a season
like that
that was the turnaround that was the
origin of a dynasty
play we've worked on all year and it
really hasn't worked like it did today i
was the secondary receiver freddie was
supposed to get the ball it became wide
open joe made a great throw
what's the name of the plan
next thing we've got a little more of a
passing situation is a sprint ride
option you know we'd already scored on
the play earlier in the game first and
goal on the cowboy eight montana throws
to solomon who goes
for three years we've been running this
play
and we had never thrown the ball to
dwight
earlier in the year in training camp
bill called us over one day made us do
this
joe try try uh
try that that little technique
not as high as i threw to dwight but
hands lengths above his head so that if
he misses it it goes out of bounds
in practice we'd roll right and joe
would hit me you know in the chest no
joe no not
hot so then he'd throw it you know five
feet over my head
and you know we'd practice and practice
it and
every now and then it would be you know
close to the right place that's good
and both dwight and i are looking at him
going he's going senile man
we never thought about you on this
there was a timeout i went down to a
knee but i could hear him talking about
sprint ride option coming up
he's going to break up and break into
the corner okay got it dwight will clear
it dwight is in here sliding back out
this is great when they're tired and
they're confused they want to get back
to dallas this is when you knock their
ass off from this one if you don't get
what you want you'll just throw it
simply throw the ball away you're ready
to go to dwight you got it
joe was saying freddie i'm going to come
to you
and then as we're breaking the huddle
he's like dwight be ready
unfortunately this time freddy falls
down
and dwight sees it and he knows that he
needs to get to the back of the end zone
and slide along the back side of the end
zone
my amazement with joe is always that
in the
the freaking situation that sends you to
the super bowl he's rolling right freddy
slips and he's covered
there's three cowboys in front of him so
he can't run has the calm to say i gotta
get these guys up in the air pumps them
they jump and then he throws it in the
exact spot it had to be it was just a
perfect
pass magical moment
from joe montana
so i was at the catch
you know joe throws a touchdown pass to
dwight clark
everyone jumped up and i got freaked out
my mom's got a really cute picture of
her holding me i was four years old and
i'm crying because i can't see anything
probably my first football memory
was that game
decades later
the catch is still as iconic as it was
in january of 1982
when montana and clark executed it
the catch will be around
forever
i think there was
a big sigh of relief because that was
such an important game for us to get
past because the preparation that went
into it knowing that
what the results would be if we won
made it that much more special
it was great to be the cowboys but now
we were going to the super
bowl and the quarterback number 16 joe
montana
[Applause]
[Music]
i think it'll be a high scoring game i
can see scoring all day my head says san
francisco my heart says it's a bengals
by a touchdown there is no question in
my mind grant cincinnati will win this
game